the principles of what we do are pretty
much the same as they've been for 80
years you know I mean they were doing
this kind of prosthetics in a way on
things like The Wizard of Oz and even
earlier than that so the basic principle
of the approach is the same but the
materials have changed and technology
has changed so nowadays we're using
silicon as a mistake medium it's a it's
a very soft gel like medium that is very
flesh like it's translucent the old
prosthetics used to be foam rubber they
were opaque so they reflected light very
strangely so you had to use a lot of
grease color and really paint them but
um nowadays with the high definition and
you just can't do that kind of makeup
and really pass it for absolutely real
the technology around filmmaking has
changed just just an at an unprecedented
speed and level over the last 10 years
we know we're going into a new
renaissance of digital filmmaking that's
changing everything but even in the more
traditional craft such as costume makeup
and here the the new technologies of
camera work the fact that we're now
shooting on 48 frames 3d high-def means
that the technology within the cameras
can see everything the the level that we
now have to lift our prosthetic work to
on The Hobbit every single one of our
characters was full in crellick are
capsulated silicon gel prosthetics that
sounds highly technical but it it's so
that the the camera now that is looking
into the surface of the skin and seeing
the translucency of the of the face
reads the prosthetic as equally as it
reads the skin of the actor the high
definition has given us more problems in
as much as that it is actually so
crystal clear but there are various ways
of using it and depending on the DOP is
- how many filters they use and their
lighting
sometimes it is much more of a problem
and sometimes it isn't you know if
you've got a real problem
your DOP very kindly often helps you out
with
shadow or just as you know a softening
of the light
you always work closely with your
cinematographer because they're gonna be
your best friend you know they help with
the work obviously and you all work as
hard as each other is it's like a game
of let's pretend but we all have to play
let's pretend as hard as each other and
work hand in glove and be close and
collaborative and that's when it works
the first object is to read the script
break down the characters and then start
you know either
researching the characters if they're
real people in life find all their
pictures or if not that you're creating
ie you know with Pirates of the
Caribbean where you're you know half of
it is actual actual period soldiers and
things like that from seventeen hundred
and eighty whatever and others are all
fantasy that you're creating and coming
up with and thinking about how to do
well if you do a period film then you
need to do research so you have to know
the look of the period and I always find
it useful to actually go ten years
either side of the year you're actually
filming because as in life now not
everyone follows that fashion or that
look for that moment so you want a
little bit of leeway 10 years in either
direction of that period so that older
people within the cast or in the
background can look time appropriate so
you create a world you create a world
that's believable I remember one makeup
artist said the most valuable thing ever
to me says don't do it like you think it
looks do it like it actually is so if
you keep that in mind you simply can't
go wrong
but somebody wants to start off in the
industry ultimately I hope they become a
makeup designer but they're going to
have to sort of start at the bottom as a
trainee and then as an assistant to get
as much education you know find a good
college which will give them a good
basic knowledge in hair and makeup and
some prosthetics those prosthetic Tsar
becoming you know used more and more and
then
it's a hard sell to sell themselves to
productions as a trainee and frequently
you have to do it on very little money
and then hopefully get your big break by
starting to do dailies at a proper rate
and then you work your way up
determination
obviously artistic some sort of artistic
ability it helps but I think it's the
same as anything else you know just be
prepared to learn look lesson work hard
all those sorts of things I mean I've
seen them as successful people in this
business come from the most diverse
backgrounds so there's definitely you
know nothing holding anybody back if you
want to do it just go hard what we look
for in people is passion enthusiasm
tenacity and then talent passion is
what's in your heart
but enthusiasm is the ability to take
that passion and turn it into an action
all of that's good and well but if you
don't have tenacity stickability because
so much of what we do is just plodding
along sticking with it making a sure
that you've forged through to the end
regardless of how challenging it may be
and then talent so and we're very much
of the view that should we find a
passionate and enthusiastic and
tenacious person talent will quickly
come because once they're in the
workshop and they're being nurtured by
the team leaders and learning as they go
they'll they'll within the rich
environment of creativity they'll be
able to find these skills their artistic
capabilities and and rise to the job I
always think that if you don't know
something you have to admit it and then
ask the question of someone who does
know that's how we all know no one
actually starts off with all the
knowledge of the world and actually when
I meet you know new makeup people and
they've got this certificate God loved
them from whatever makeup school and and
think that they are now a makeup artist
it always surprises me because I've been
doing this for thirty years and I still
wonder if I ever make
artist one day I would like to be a
really good one I'm not there yet